hallo mein name sogar etliche leute
sagen hier weht schon ok mit laden
reiter und warum das ist der grund
gewesen
ein komplett neues immer irgendwie etwas
ihr bisher noch gar nicht in meinem
video gesehen hatte habe ich hier und da
hinten mitte
[Musik]
aber ich kann man auf dem turm ein
kumpel marken vor einigen tagen nach
köln gezogen der woche noch nicht reif
ist und da ich gesagt habe okay nach
vorne wenn ich das im eingangsbereich
auch nie mehr wieder aufnehmen nach
hinten einfach dieses thema jetzt meinen
augen ist immer dafür brauchte ich
allerdings noch ein bisschen kleineren
schreibt bestimmte währung gefordert
wegen waren heute bei kia und am mund
halten schreibtisch gekauften und den
entsprechenden auch ein transporter
mieten und praktische mitnehmen das
natürlich auch schon wert plateau bendig
und waren sie auch schon davor um das
heutige video handeln soll
was mache ich eigentlich nur auf meine
weitere youtube.com flash luca
allerdings wenn die beute hier für mein
haupt ab sie hätten einfach kein video
heute hier über den hauptkanal gehabt
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
zeige euch heute einfach mal unseren
trip tweet her
wir müssen beachten dass ich jetzt nicht
mit dieser fetten wäre hier hingegangen
bin und das gebraucht habe und so
sondern ich hab's mir beim handy ins
netz hochgeladen zeigt euch jetzt meine
snapped orientieren
und hätte davon etwa fünf auf elf ab
matti müller
hallo oder sein
red
wir bringen jetzt gastransporte
zurücktritt her nordbank wollte war
vorhin ausgeliehen haben muss ich gut
gefahren teams im kopf was passiert
zeigt euch doch wir mussten so einen
guten kampf unternehmen und user
komplett unsere leute dann auch das ende
von unserer reifen bitten das habe ich
ja schon gesagt es ist nicht der
placement ikea werbe videos in whatever
sondern einfach nur ja unser tipp dahin
wie möglich her auch gar nicht so sehr
aber es soll jetzt nicht in die werbe
belastend sein dieses video und das
wartet doch wir vom gesamten video also
wie gesagt hätte jetzt keine große zeit
mehr jetzt noch irgendwas aufzunehmen
weil ich auf der veralteten muss der
wirtschaft lernen und mutter noch den
schreibtisch auch rapid wenn euch das
video gleich gefallen hat würden wir uns
mega waren live freuen weil machen ich
bin total bescheuert also to fly the
history also falsche verdummt jetzt very
sorry wir jetzt noch dran weiter
schreibt malblock in die kommentare
dann weiß ich dass ihr wimmelt es fast
genauso gesagt wie wir hier findet ihr
auch ein zweiter gewertet werden könnte
meinen kanal direkt abonnieren und hier
findet irgend ein anderes video
eingeblendet
[Musik]